- [Instructor] You know what a magnet is,
but did you know that some
magnets can be turned on and off?
One type of temporary magnet
is called an electromagnet.
So what is electromagnetism?
Well, the hint is in the name itself.
Electro for electrical,
and magnet for, well, magnet.
Let's take a moment to
look at the definition
of what an electromagnet is.
Electromagnets are materials
that become magnets
in the presence of electricity.
But how does that even happen?
Well, it turns out
that electrically-charged
particles in motion
actually have small
magnetic fields around them.
So, if we run electricity through a wire,
a magnetic field will be
created around the wire.
Now, we can control the
strength of this magnetic field
in a couple of ways.
We can move more electric
charges through the wire
at a faster rate,
and we do this by increasing
the electrical current.
The second way is to increase the density
of the charged particles,
and we can do this by
looping the wire into a coil.
This gives us more charged particles
with magnetic fields in a small space,
strengthening the magnetic force.
The other thing we can
control with electromagnets
is the direction of the magnetic field,
and we can do this by
changing the direction
of the electricity.
So if we go back to this
wire example from earlier
and change the direction
of the electricity
running through that wire,
well, the magnetic fields
will also change direction.
This makes electromagnets quite different
from permanent magnets.
So let's take a look at that
and compare permanent
magnets to electromagnets.
Electromagnets are typically made
of loops of wire and a coil.
The wire is typically
made of metal like copper
and wrapped around pieces of metal
like iron, nickel, or cobalt.
This is different from a permanent magnet
because permanent magnets
don't need this wire.
Permanent magnets also have fixed poles.
You can't change the north and
south poles on these magnets,
but as we now know, for electromagnets,
we can change these poles
by changing the direction
of the electrical current.
So, if we have an electromagnet
with a north and south pole
that looks like this
and a current flowing in this direction,
well, we can change the poles
and the direction of the current.
Permanent magnets have a fixed strength,
but we just talked about
how we can change the
strength of electromagnets,
so electromagnets have
adjustable strength.
And finally, electromagnets
need a power source
in order to generate
the electricity required
to produce magnetic fields.
Permanent magnets do
not need a power source,
but this means that we can
also turn electromagnets
on and off,
which is pretty cool
when you think about it.
On the other hand,
permanent magnets are always on.
Now, you might be thinking
if electrical charge can affect magnetism,
can magnetism affect electrical charge?
Absolutely, let's look
at how we can do that.
The only way to do this is by
changing the magnetic field
around the charged particles.
This can be done by moving magnets closer
or further away from the particles
or by spinning the magnets.
In fact, spinning magnets is
how most of the electricity
we use in cities and homes is generated.
A turbine spins a magnet inside a coil
to produce electricity,
and since electromagnets
need a power source,
this turbine is powered by wind.
So you can see why electromagnetism
is an incredibly important force,
and this isn't the only
important application of it.
We use electromagnets in all
sorts of other applications,
from motors to speakers
and even medical scanners.